por favor tengan listos los peluches
muñecos y pañales primero esto
este hombre está cambiando un pañal
reunimos a siete padres adolescentes soy
un padre adolescente soy un padre
adolescente soy un padre adolescente soy
adolescente uno es un mentiroso si el
grupo descubre quién es el mentiroso
ganarán un premio en efectivo si el
mentiroso sobrevive él ganará el premio
esto es el impostor
mi plan es tratar de presionar a los
padres adolescentes y hacerles muchas
preguntas y ver si saben algunas cosas
sobre bebés o cómo cambiarlos recuerdan
cuánto cuesta la leche de fórmula o
cuánto cuestan los pañales es muy
confiado estoy seguro de que voy a ganar
esto
[Música]
muy bien con quién con quién pasó más
tiempo su bebé con la madre el padre
viven juntos mi novia y yo vivimos
juntos pero aún no estamos casados y
hijos se quede en casa de ella aun se
quedan conmigo el fin de semana porque
todavía está en la secundaria mi novia y
yo empezamos a vivir juntos hace poco y
vivimos todos juntos no estoy con la
mamá de mi bebé pero trato de estar con
él por lo menos cada semana mi esposa y
yo seguimos casados por lo que vivimos
juntos yo mi novia y mi hijo vivimos
todos juntos que les gusta ver a sus
hijos baby einstein no sesione escuchado
hablar de él sí y le encanta él le gusta
mucho a mi bebé le encanta ver coco me
lo exacto lo veo mejor si mi hijo ve
coco melón y bella y más y le pondría a
ver anime como naruto
genial cuál es la manera más fácil para
ustedes de calmar a sus hijos cuando
hacen berrinche la comida deja
definitivamente comida si le doy de
comer deja de llorar a mi hijo le gusta
que lo cargue y que le frote la espalda
a mi hijo tomo un chupón así que se
calma con el chupón normalmente tomo
juguetes trato de entretenerlos y luego
hablamos porque ya está grande yo solo
cargo a mi bebé ella me adora soy su
favorito si la cargo indicó su nombre
entonces todo se calma
estoy muy seguro de que no van a pensar
que fui yo porque estaba haciendo un
poco asertivo pero no quería presionar
de más creo que voy a elegir a nik voy a
votar por ethan es el que menos parece
un padre para mí cuando preguntaron cómo
calma vamos a nuestros hijos darren dijo
que tan pronto como cargada su bebé ella
dejaba de llorar eso no es del todo
realista / nick opción elegiría a nik yo
sospecho más de darren me parece que él
es el que menos hablo me di cuenta
porque se me olvidó que él estaba en la
llamada de zoom en esta ronda yo votaré
por tomás y me pareció que tartamudeaba
al responder no me gustaría lanzar una
moneda y elegir entre it and the ring
pero lancemos este control
viven muy bien listos sus votos de la
primera ronda y tenemos un empate de 3
entre hit and run inn y que wow un
empate de 3 eso significa que vamos a un
desempate cada persona tendrá 20
segundos para exponer su caso empecemos
con idán tengo 17 años mi novia quedó
embarazada cuando teníamos 16 años
mi bebé nació en julio y ahora tiene 7
meses mi novio y yo nos conocimos en
octavo grado fue entonces cuando nos
juntamos por primera vez ella quede
embarazada a los 15 y tuvo el bebé las
16 vamos a ser padre adolescente me
encanta lo que conlleva me di cuenta de
que algunas de las cosas que dije
probablemente sonaron raras como dije
que estaba casado y mostré mi mano
izquierda y no tengo un anillo mi hija
está a punto de cumplir dos años nació
en mayo y mi hijo nació en diciembre
cumplió un mes
y si el tartamudeo un poco mi cerebro se
quedó en blanco espero que haya sido
suficiente sigo pensando que es darren
yo voy a votar por ti lo siento no sé
hombre los otros dos parecen muy seguros
creo nik es seguro pero
sigo pensando que él es sospechoso la
persona eliminada en la primera ronda es
darling lo sabía sentí que iba a ser yo
no sé por qué quizá fue la forma en que
hable no lo sé
muy bien esta es una ronda de cambio de
pañales cada uno de ustedes cambiará un
pañal a un objeto inanimado demostrara a
todos lo bien que puede cambiar un pañal
por favor tengan listos sus peluches
muñecos y pañales vamos a empezar con
nyc
primero esto
ya le rompió la pierna al bebé este
hombre está cambiando un pañal es muy
rudo con él sé que no es un bebé de
verdad pero dios
y mira si eres un profesional
dependiendo de lo que sea solo deberías
necesitar dos toallitas lo está dando
todo todo tomadas lo hizo bien
así no se enrolla un pañal hermano
tiraste la toallita fuera porque tiraste
la toallita fuera del pañal
[Música]
me acaba de matar a su bebé yo creo que
el bebé murió con ese golpe después más
difícil que cambiar a mi hijo
por lo general lo que hago primero es
tomar unas toallitas las abro y le
sujetó las piernas bien doblando las
piernas bien lo pongo debajo de ella y
hacia atrás hay que apretarlo así cuando
le pongo el driver gini a mí también me
gusta hacer eso cuando le cambiaba el
pañal siempre pienso de ajustarlo tira
de estos lados así estará muy bien
cubierta
al desabrochar lo se tira de esto hacia
abajo mantenlo debajo de ella yo tengo
una niña así que siempre es el interés
de abajo así que ahí están las toallitas
normalmente se acerca causó más y los
pongo aquí adentro estaba a punto de
decir por qué no ponen las toallitas en
el pañal pero lo hizo la ranura es
bastante grande para esto pero como ven
está listo para ser sincero creo que lo
hice bien tarde un poco más que la
mayoría pero fue muy completo creo que
votaré por pasión creo que esa ya lo
hizo muy bien con el cambio de pañales y
jon apuesta en esta ronda votaré por
nick debido al desempate de la última
ronda y por sus pobres habilidades
cambiando pañales todavía sospecho un
poco de nick votaré por estás young en
esta ronda es un poco difícil de decidir
el top es muy bueno yo solo voto por
tracción porque se le cayó el bebé
contamos los votos y la persona
eliminada en esta ronda es
estás young
wow demonios
realmente pensé que me iban a expulsar
en esta ronda entiendo por qué me
eliminaron probablemente sea porque dejé
caer a pikachu pero eso solo porque no
tenía suficiente espacio aquí
creo que muchos piensan en padres
adolescentes como algo patético como que
no van a estar allí para sus hijos no se
van a quedar no se preocupan están allí
para la chica hasta que ésta se va
podría ser cierto para algunos padres
pero creo que en el esquema de las cosas
sin ninguno de nosotros es el topo
estamos aquí genuinamente para nuestro
sí es cierto que la vida es un cambio al
100% cuando tienes un hijo tu
perspectiva de la vida todo lo que
pensabas que sabías se va por la ventana
pero sé que tener un hijo realmente te
hace madurar rápido que finalmente
rápido cuál fue la reacción de sus
padres con el embarazo
terrible de sus novias también porque es
cuando empiezan las buenas reacciones
bueno la mamá de mi novia la ha hecho y
se vino a vivir conmigo s luego un año
después nos echaron a ambos ahora
vivimos con su padre con el que no ha
hablado durante seis años del lado de mi
madre le encantó es muy feminista le
gustó saber que iba a tener una niña
estaba muy contenta del lado de mi padre
mi hermano me dio un puñetazo porque no
estaba muy contento por parte de su mamá
estuvo a punto de llevarme a tribunales
pero creo que todo está bien ahora papá
la que más me apoyó en ese momento de mi
vida mi mamá estaba muy decepcionada
porque soy el más joven pensó que le
había fallado luego mi papá acabó
hablando con ella y la termino
tranquilizando un poco la familia de mi
esposa estaba toda de enojada me
disgustó porque nos presionaron para
abortar oye tienes 16 años tienes que
abordar el acuerdo que cuando estaba en
la secundaria ella quedó embarazada y
uno de los profesores nos dijo deberían
abortar lo creo que esa fue una de las
peores partes sobre eso el que
repitieran constantemente que
abordáramos la mamá de mi novia le dijo
que era su decisión abortar y quedarse
en casa o tener el niño y será echada
nunca tuve que pasar por eso
personalmente soy probide así que
gracias a todos por no tomar esa
decisión mis opiniones se han cambiado
porque tuvo un bebé así que ahora que
tengo este apego no puedo ver a nadie
haciendo eso es algo tan horrible con
esta ronda siento que es difícil
eliminar a alguien porque siento que
todos tenían una buena historia
convincente en esta ronda voy a votar
por nick sólo por sus rondas anteriores
sigo sospechando de mí
y para ser honesto ahora estoy
sospechando de tomás realmente no siento
que nadie sea el topo pero lo siento si
yo elijo tomar solo porque estado
callado por mucho tiempo voy a votar por
son en esta ronda tenemos que votar así
que como tengo que votar te contamos los
votos si hay un empate entre sesión y
tomas cada uno de ustedes tendrá 20
segundos para exponer su caso y vamos a
empezar con tomás mi hijo ya tiene
44 años y
diablos me enredé son tantas cosas es
algo tan hermoso tener un hijo y estar
todos los días con él y poder tenerlo
cerca y divertirme con él creo que lo
más importante de ser padre es amar a tu
hijo incondicionalmente e incluso con
nuestra esposa o novia por ejemplo
simplemente aprendes a ser padre y una
pareja también aprendes que hay
diferencias que vas a discutir con ellos
pero también tienes tus funciones
parentales y no dejas que eso se
interponga en la crianza de tu hijo
estoy empezando a sentir no sé que estoy
un poco en el lado de shawn creo mi voto
va para tomás son lo hizo muy bien al
hablar voy a votar porción sé que dije
tomas pero yo nunca dijo realmente mi
bebé siempre dijo el tuyo ya que no
tiene uno la persona eliminada en esta
ronda es
son ojo estoy un poco enojado un poco
molesto por haber sido eliminado creo
que todos confiamos de verdad en los
demás pero tenemos que pasar la ronda
alta en el pulgar hacia arriba si
quieren continuar el juego sino denle un
pulgar hacia abajo si quieren terminar
de jugar a ver quién baja el pulgar
primero muéstrenme sus pulgares en
muy bien estamos mitad y mitad
voy a sacar a tomar vamos a votar una
vez más no lo cambio sino en cambios 2 1
de acuerdo y ha cambiado su voto
continuamos el juego muchos atrás fuera
sea más la cuarta ronda
de acuerdo tomas si no has hablado mucho
de tu novia hace cuánto fue que
terminaron nunca terminamos entonces
empezaron de hecho ahora vivimos juntos
me di cuenta de que no tienes ningún
juguete del bebé tienes alguno por ahí
si los tengo por navidad le regalaron
varios de toy story quieren que les
muestre sí sí bueno tengo un buzz
lightyear se lo regalaron antes de
navidad en realidad qué edad tiene tu
hijo tiene 4 años cómo fue su
experiencia cuando su pareja estaba en
parto el parto se adelantó en realidad
no me dejaron entrar en la habitación
porque dijeron es una emergencia así que
me hicieron esperar en una sala y estuve
allí esperando nervioso con mis
experiencias mi bebé fue una cesárea yo
no estaba allí fue durante toda la cosa
del cob y no pude estar allí y no me
dejaron entrar el bebé nació conseguir
fotos justamente cuando nació son las
mejores fotos que he tenido en mi vida
me encantan mi bebé nació de forma
natural en realidad vino tres semanas
antes de la fecha prevista de hecho
tuvieron que inducir a mi novia 20
minutos hermanos juro que pensé que iba
a tardar una eternidad pero fue rápido
la primera vez con mi hija cuando
finalmente comenzó a empujar en realidad
empujo durante unos dos minutos y se
hizo rápido sin embargo con mi hijo fue
diferente el anestesista estaba haciendo
una epidural para otra persona así que
mi mujer estuvo a punto de tener un
parto natural de elegir a alguien
probablemente serían y la forma en que
explicaba las cosas era un poco
inestable yo votaba por nick en la
primera ronda pero ahora tomás me parece
más sospechoso voy a votar por tomás en
esta ronda voy a tener que decir tomás
no no no no lo sé no sé no sé nada ya
están los votos para la cuarta ronda y
el eliminado de esta ronda es
tomás
lo siento más lo sabía me imaginaba que
iban a hacer eso muy bien hacen un
pulgar hacia arriba si quieren continuar
el juego sino denle un pulgar hacia
abajo si crees que encontraron al topo y
quieren terminar el juego tengo mis
sospechas sobre nick pero al final salió
adelante así que vamos a ver tengo mucho
miedo de que sea nick pero lo he dado
todo si no ganamos no ganamos espero que
tengamos razón en esto creo que estamos
en la misma página muestra en esos
pulgares en
3-2-1
bien todo el mundo ha votado con los
pulgares hacia abajo vamos a terminar el
juego ahora
de acuerdo si el fondo se vuelve verde
todos ganan si es rojo el topo sigue en
el juego y todos ustedes pierden en 3 2
dios mío
no no voy a mentir sospechaba de lo
mismo yo sospechaba mucho de ti pero
después de la primera me dije no no hay
manera
el juego ha terminado y los padres
adolescentes han ganado eso significa
que los ganadores recibirán un premio en
efectivo ahora podría el falso padre
adolescente levantar la mano en
que
lo sabía lo sabía
bueno en realidad mi hermano fue un
padre adolescente así que trate de
representar sus experiencias como si
fuera mías su hija todavía vive con
nosotros pero ahora tiene 7 años y
también me enseñó a cambiar pañales
salud a los bebés saluda míralos a todos
esta es mi niña
este es mi hijo acabo de cumplir dos
años su nombre es el ereim el a por el
personaje the rainbow six y el
videojuego bonito me encanta si te
saluda saluda este es mi hijo y les dije
que le gusta buzz lightyear se los dije
no estaba mintiendo hasta luego
nos vemos
[Música]